there have been some outtakes released
from this stunning interview that Kanye
West did with Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson that are so insane and so
anti-semitic that they raise a whole new
series of questions about Kanye's
seeming obsession with the Jews or Jew
as he sometimes refers to them this is
super interesting so over the last week
there's been a lot happening with a
musical artist Kanye West wherein he
showed up in Europe with a white lives
matter shirt and then he appeared with
Tucker Carlson and talked about how
great Trump is and it was like really a
very kind of fawning interview of course
because Kanye West has become useful to
the right and then he ended up getting
suspended from multiple social media
platforms for uh basically just going on
an anti-semitic tirade and attacking
Jews and saying I think Diddy is
controlled by Jews and all this
different stuff
vice's motherboard that's the source for
these clips has now uncovered
clips from the Tucker Carlson interview
that were cut from what was broadcast
and they are absolutely and utterly
insane and we're going to look at a
couple of these and I what I want to
mention to people is
I think my audience mostly knows I'm
Jewish
I have had
experiences with anti-semites of every
flavor casual anti-semites who just
unthinkingly have attached themselves to
the very easy tropes you know oh Jews
are cheap that's one I dealt with with
other employees when I worked at Circuit
City I've recently tweeted about that
there's also the sort of more
conspiratorial people about an elitist
cabal Bilderberg Rothschild you know
this sort of stuff then there's also the
black Israelites which we're going to
get into in a moment there's all sorts
of these different flavors and some
people are just obsessed with Jews they
look at Jews as the sole cause of
everything that is bad uh on our planet
okay let's get into the first clip in
this is an outtake okay
Kanye says that the founder of Planned
Parenthood
uh created Planned Parenthood with the
KKK to control the Jew population and
again this one you could say this one is
not overtly anti-semitic but it's all
part of the obsession with Jews check
this out let's go to the first one
Planned Parenthood was made by Margaret
Sanger
a known Eugenics with the KKK
to control
the Jew population when I say Jew I mean
the 12 lost tribes of Judah the blood of
Christ who
the race the people known as the race
black Billy R this is who our people are
yeah this is this is super confusing so
try to follow along the blood of Christ
this as a Christian is my belief and I
believe that if we saw ourselves as more
yeah
so
first of all Margaret Sanger
early sort of women's rights and Family
Planning Advocate uh was Jewish as far
as my research revealed so the idea that
she wanted to control the Jew population
I don't really know what Kanye means
control it by lowering it or boosting it
I don't know this is all completely
Bonkers now when Kanye talks about
the race black are the real Jews I know
some in my audience already know about
this and some don't there is a movement
called the black Israelites or the
Hebrew Israelites it is a movement that
goes back to the late 1800s where some
mostly Pentecostal black Christians
started to claim that in a revelation
they learned they were the true Hebrews
you can find examples of the term
Hebrews Israelites the real Jews
whatever
generally speaking this is a pretty
racist movement in the modern day they
claim that Jews are sort of devilish
imposters and that the real Jews are
black folks okay
um
let's let's leave it there
was another clip in which Kanye used a
weird metaphor
and then brings up the Jews again in the
metaphor and then asks for it to be cut
from the interview to which you'll
notice Tucker Carlson says done when
Kanye says I want that cut out Tucker
says done this also is interesting
because it exposes that more than likely
part of the agreement for this interview
was Kanye has sort of like final edit
and can ask for anything to be cut how
common that is on Tucker Carlson's show
I don't know I've never given that to
anybody on our program exactly what our
culture is based on think about us
judging each other on how white we could
talk would be like
you know
a Jewish person judging another Jewish
person on how good they danced
or something I mean that's probably like
a bad uh as I remember people gonna get
mad at that but
uh
uh another thing that they do
um
that I probably want to edit that out if
I like that done Tucker says consider it
done Kanye you're producing here okay so
you know I was talking to Ice Cube Today
and we got really beat up in 2020 for
saying we need to approach things a
different way and not just be trauma
drunk right which is a term that I you
know God okay so again the example he
tries to go to is something about Jews
obsessed with Jews realizes it's going
nowhere and then asks for it to be cut
out a small note here Kanye did say
during the interview that he's
vaccinated that was cut out from the
final cut that aired I don't think that
was Kanye's request that seems to be a
Fox News decision you know every day
we've been killing each other
in the streets every day one of the
amazing things with uh mayor Suarez is
the the murder rate has gone down and
yeah I don't I mean you set that
question up you have more information
about the uh
about the uh about what happened in the
hospitals so in all honesty I don't I
don't have the the most facts that
that's manufacturing I mean in your life
like somebody
vaccine the being stuck inside like what
did you think of all that I was I was
vaccinated it was interesting a friend
of mine so I was vaccinated was removed
from the Final Cut and then lastly here
just again the continued obsession with
Jewish people and in this one he does
the
um sort of sort of like money Trope
where he says he would rather his kids
know about Hanukkah rather than Kwanzaa
because it'll come with some Financial
engineering and again this is the the
idea that Jews control the financial
system and this is one of the oldest
anti-semitic claims around and and
Kanye's full in on it listen to this
listen how casually he mentions this too
biting my tongue on my political opinion
because I thought it would be better for
my children and now you look up and my
kids are going to a school that teaches
black kids a complicated Kwanzaa
I prefer my kids new Hanukkah than
Kwanzaa at least it will come with some
Financial engineering
Kwanzaa doesn't you know so
um and by the way I could tell you at
Hanukkah nobody talks to you about IRAs
or compounding interests it's just not
it's not where I ever learned about that
stuff he's obsessed with Jewish people
and I have seen people like this there
are folks who get fixated on
particular things and sometimes it's you
know the hammer that turns everything
into a nail for them is Jews sometimes
it's you know uh the trilateral
commission sometimes it's geoengineering
or control through fluoride in the water
system or whatever the case may be Fox
News has sort of backed off with a
number of segments in the last 24 hours
saying
the interview the White lives matter
thing is interesting
but all the Tweet the anti-semitic
tweets that's too far Maria Bartiromo
for example and others and they're
chalking this up to mental illness and
again
sure mental illness can be a factor but
most mentally ill people don't become
obsessed with the Jews really Bonkers
stuff from Kanye and I find it all to be
completely horrible
I've seen several people in my life try
to quit smoking or vaping and quitting
has so many benefits but it does require
a strategy and our sponsor fume is a
one-of-a-kind inhaler that can help you
quit smoking as a replacement for the
hand-to-mouth habit of smoking there is
no smoke there is no vapor and there's
no nicotine fume is just a small inhaler
handcrafted from wood it uses cores
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy instead of a
nasty cigarette or a vape you can use
fume while flying which is a big plus
because there's no smoke no Vapor no
nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and Conquer with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai I love chai myself and lemon
berry Bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the Vapes head
over to
breathefume.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 10 off your entire order
the link is down below